hi I'm Evan Carmichael your friend and
all things entrepreneurship today I'm
doing another one of my fiber gigs and
reviewing a website from one of my
readers LJ Walker and LJ his business
here is my MC a pro com and this is some
information about the website so looking
at the site it's a cleanly designed it
looks very professional and looks like
it's some kind of network marketing
program where typically they give you a
website and you can see here it's my MC
a pro com /l jaywalker so that's that's
LJ's own personal domain for this and
these are typically very hard to
customize now let's see how good a job
the organization has done here at doing
it oh this is a video here which is
great welcome to my site the first thing
that pops out is I'm wondering what do
these guys do so it says my motor club
of america so i i'm not quite sure what
it is that we're selling it looks like
there's an opportunity to make some
money looking at the testimonials I've
been in MCA for a few months now and for
the first time I have no money worries
so it is an opportunity to make money i
would put something here if it's
possible to change instead of walking to
my site put a one-sentence explain what
it is that you're selling here so i said
the video will explain a little bit more
would be great to see one sentence so if
I land on this page it quickly explains
what it is that you do so i can quickly
get that grasp I like that it's 1926
established so it adds a little more
credibility a lot of these programs are
you know they just set up their
fly-by-night that promise you to make a
lot of money and then they go away so
that's great that it's been around for
so long I love that there are
testimonials here this is awesome again
some proof to show that you know this is
this is a good opportunity for people if
possible be great to see pictures of
these people it just makes a little more
believable to hit home
little more people love seeing people's
faces so if these people do have faces
and you have the ability to edit that I
definitely put those in as much as
possible if I scroll up we've got a
phone number here that we can call
obvious this LG Walker so this is your
own home page we've got facebook and
twitter let's see what's happening on
facebook the facebook page just loads
the same page let's see what Twitter and
the Twitter page does the same thing so
I probably remove those because it's not
really adding to the experience here for
people who are coming to your website
the biggest thing that I probably
improve on this is I would put your own
story this is where a lot of these
network marketing things fall down
because people like to buy from people
and so I would want to see your story
you know if I click here on your name or
maybe here underneath this put LG Walker
big smiling face how you got started why
you love this business how much money
you're making our new people that you
signed up and why you're excited about
this opportunity the more you can make
it personal and make people want to be
like you then the more likely they're
going to want to take the next step and
do whatever it is that you want them to
do so I definitely try to improve on
that section hopefully as an option to
edit the page table to put your own
story in there often on these types of
sites that are given by the company it's
not possible so you have to create your
own website to do it but it's definitely
worth putting in the time to try to
figure that out because it can make a
huge difference on your conversions
having that you're kind of stock Corp
corporate site versus having something
that clearly explains your story and why
you're excited about
so let's learn a little bit more let's
check out the compensation see what
these guys are all about so let's see
how we can make money different ways
direct sales overrides matrix reward
bonus residual income is always
something people are looking for so
here's an example of money you can make
so we get advanced Commission Commission
grains per week per month per year and
this is great if you can make money on
an ongoing basis from signing somebody
up it's always a much more attractive
option for people to want to join this
kind of thing and make a business from
it and that should probably be
highlighted on the homepage right away
there's an opportunity to make recurring
income from one time sales because a lot
of these programs you have to keep
selling new people in order to make any
kind of money so this is you know every
year this is a potential lifetime
benefit to them as long as these people
stay as part of the program that's a
huge option that's a huge selling point
for anybody who's considering joining
this kind of program so I again find a
way to put that in here or maybe that's
why you signed up and you can put that
as part of your story but that's
definitely a big benefit that should be
highlighted and somebody who's
considering joining this program that
would be a big selling point for them
let's go down to testimonials and see
what you have here so this page looks
blank so it says my story which really
should say testimonials but it looks
like you have a place here to tell your
story which is great so you want to use
this put a picture you know nice smiling
picture trustworthy happy person loves
their business and talk about how you
got started you know why you love this
business what did you hope to do when
you first started signed up for it why
is it exciting for you what kind of
early results have you had you don't
have to be killing it yet but showing
some early results even or talk about
how you got your first sale and how
excited you felt about it and how you
know you're going to be building your
business from this and building
income and supporting your family from
this that kind of excitement gets people
going ties it to you and makes them want
to be like you and so they'll take the
next step whatever it is a you a sin to
take so overall good site hopefully that
helps give you some suggestions for what
to do next I think it is an interesting
opportunity but again you know clearly
explain one line what it is that this is
all about and if you can put pictures
that'd be great but the biggest thing
missing is still your story and creating
an ongoing discussion if you can
creating content whether their YouTube
posts or blog posts or Twitter posts
just hitting people over again with why
you're doing this and updating them with
some of the progress and success that
you've had as they see these messages
keep coming at them they're going to be
interested in taking the next step in
signing up one last thing you might want
to do is create some kind of newsletter
an option to leave their name and email
address and you can contact them every
so often if it's once a week or every
two weeks or every month with an update
via email it could be hard for somebody
to come here and want to just sign up
right away and join but they're more
likely to leave their email for some
kind of free report or free download and
then you can start building a
conversation with them and share things
that inspire you and motivate you and
again all the things that you're doing
to grow this business can help motivate
them to want to sign up and sign up
under your team specifically so
hopefully they'll help good luck with
the business keep us posted I want to
see how this thing how this thing goes
for you for those of you watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up makes you want to do more for you and
I'd love to hear we get to think if you
won't leave a comment under the video I
always read those love seemed to come in
so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you